il fut un temps question de l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines on
pensait la commune de tireurs vallat
grignon tout proche de l'emporter
finalement c'est bien là poissy que le
psg va installer son nouveau camp
d'entraînement un éthiquement aménagé au
bord de la nationale 13 près de
l'autoroute a13 et du centre hospitalier
intercommunal qui s'étend sur près de 70
hectares le département la ville
propriétaire du terrain aucun recours
n'est envisageable les travaux
pourraient commencer l'an prochain pour
une livraison en 2000 à 19,14 terrain de
football un stade de 5000 places vont
être réalisés
la ville de poissy prévoit la
mobilisation de 1000 salariés une
aubaine économique
pour le maire karl olive
particulièrement actif sur ce dossier
avec le soutien également du député
david douillet l'arrivée du psg sera
bénéfique pour le dynamisme sportif
économique et sociale alors du côté de
saint germain en laye l'heure est en
revanche à la déception
saint germain avait pourtant présenté un
nouveau site en décembre dernier sans
succès donc